in the opening scene we see a thug
sneaking into a secluded modern home
inside a man named Adam is carrying a
tray of food and walking down the
hallway during this he senses someone
behind his back just as he turns around
the Intruder wearing a ski mask attacks
him with a baseball bat rendering him
unconscious the scene then cuts to the
past where we are introduced to Adam's
daughter Alice who is in the midst of a
medical session the doctor presents her
with three cylindrical objects of
different sizes he then shows her a
mechanical arm and attaches it to her
body once done the doctor asks her to
try grabbing the cylindrical objects and
balancing them on a table it turns out
that the device is operated by her
thoughts and Alice who has anger issues
finds it challenging due to her
impatience failing for the first time
frustrates her and she asks the doctor
to take it off however the latter
suggests that she keep trying with
patience after the doctor leaves Adam
asks how she feels but Alice evades his
questions and asks him to to let her
mother out following this she stands in
front of her mother's room and a white
Wolfhound named beatric walks out here
it's revealed that Alice refers to the
dog as her mother she shows beatric the
prosthetic limb and the dog who has a
speech generating device on her collar
says that it doesn't have Alice's scent
the girl then uses her saliva to leave
her scent on the mechanical arm later on
Alice is with her father trying to use
the mechanical arm she successfully
picks up a thicker cylindrical object
and places it down successfully however
she gives up when she fails to pick up
the second one her father asks her to
try it one more time but Alice vents her
frustration on the objects and decides
to take a walk with her mom while
walking in the woods Alice and beatric
stumble upon a black metal cube out of
curiosity she proceeds to touch it
causing a square opening to appear she
nervously reaches her hand inside and
retrieves a piece of paper with a note
that reads they are not to be trusted
the handwriting looks familiar to Alice
so she hurries back home and copies the
note only to discover that it resembles
her own scared she decides to share this
unusual incident with her father but he
is currently wandering around the forest
a short while later Adam returns home
with two teenagers one of whom appears
to be brutally injured he hurriedly
takes the injured Erica to the small
pool while her younger brother Paul
watches her cry in pain the scream
reaches Alice's ear but she hesitates to
go check after after attending to
Erica's wound Adam and Dallas try to
talk to the siblings asking about what
happened Erica answers their questions
as her brother is a mute she reveals
that her boyfriend David is the one who
did this to her she goes on to explain
that she had gone on a picnic with him
but Paul secretly followed them he
accidentally caught them having an
intimate moment upon seeing her brother
Erica asked David to stop but the latter
got aggressive and assaulted her in
addition Erica discloses that her
parents have already passed and they
live alone in town after hearing their
story Adam permits them to stay there
for a night and Promises to drop them
home the following day in the next scene
Erica consoles her brother assuring him
that everything will be okay she also
asks if Paul likes Alice but before he
can respond beatric enters to check on
them Erica asks the dog about Alice's
arm but it simply Dodges the question it
can be tough to get an answer out of a
dog this annoys her so she pushes it out
and locks the door after this beatric
returns to Alice and claims that the
siblings don't smell good just then they
spot something outside their house and
instantly alert Adam the ladder grabs a
kitchen knife and looks through the
window but he sees nothing as a result
he Comforts them and sends them back to
their beds telling them not to worry the
following morning Adam helps Alice in
attaching her mechanical arm during
which she admits that she knows he has a
liking for Erica as a result of this she
suggests that he allow the siblings to
stay there for an additional day
following this Alice heads toward the
living room where she finds Paul playing
with her cylindrical objects he sets up
the objects for Alice allowing her to
practice as before she succeeds in
placing the first one but fails the
second one this frustration almost leads
her to leave but Paul stops her and
helps her with the second object however
when it comes to the third one Alice
still lacks the necessary patience this
once again makes her angry but Paul
helps her calm down with a comforting
hug initially Alice feels better but she
soon realizes that Erica is missing
sensing something am Miss Alice rushes
towards her father's room only to
discover him caressing Erica's face in
front of beatric this sight fills her
with anger and cringe prompting her to
storm off Adam tries to reason with her
explaining that the dog isn't her mother
however Alice accuses him of
transforming her mother into a wolfhound
and also holds him responsible for her
missing arm in an effort to convince her
otherwise Adam falsely claims he killed
her mother but Alice doesn't want want
to listen when she addresses him as a
cold-hearted murderer Adam loses his
temper and yells at her before walking
away in the aftermath of their
confrontation Alice leaves the house
with beatric she returns to the Black
Cube and touches it once more this time
she receives a microchip with a note
instructing her to play an audio file
exactly at 400 p.m. using headphones
Alice follows the instructions patiently
waiting for the designated time at 400
p.m. she plays the audio file hearing a
Fe female voice that directs her to
follow her instructions step by step
firstly Alice is tasked to go to her
father and notify him that David is
outside the voice warns her not to let
him call the police or else things will
get worse Alice heeds The Voice
convincing her father to inspect the
surroundings outside once Adam departs
Alice follows the instructions and
approaches Paul She leads him into the
kitchen offering to make him a sandwich
much to her shock The Voice directs her
to grab a kitchen knife and to kill the
siblings terrified by this command she
decides to leave however the voice
asserts that she is trying to prevent a
dire event but it always ends in the
same way it also warns that things will
get terrible if Alice doesn't kill them
amidst this Paul walks closer prompting
Alice to grab a knife but strangely he
leans towards her and kisses her on the
lips shortly after Erica shows up and
asks Alice about her father's
whereabouts the latter pretends to have
no idea and walks away after preparing a
sandwich for Paul later that night Adam
and Dallas go to bed while the siblings
stay awake after a while Paul helps his
sister in taking off her clothes after
which she walks to Adam's room naked
simultaneously Paul who knows the door
passcode unlocks it and allows a masked
man to enter the house after a while
Erica leads Adam out of his room as he
follows her the masked man suddenly
appears behind him fatally slits his
throat and fleases the scene with the
siblings that plan was more complicated
and more sexy than it needed to be
sometime later Alice is awakened by a
noise and walks through the hallway to
check to her horror she discovers her
father's lifeless body lying on the
floor while grieving for him she
suddenly realizes her mother's absence
and rushes in search of her
unfortunately the dog has also been
killed brutally overwhelmed by this
tragic turn of events Alice breaks down
in tears crying out in anguish the next
morning she wakes up pondering how the
Black Cube knew of this tragic sequence
in Hope of finding answers she heads to
the forest and touches the cube but this
time it remains unresponsive unlike
before panicked Alice Taps it repeatedly
while screaming at the top of her lungs
after a brief moment the cube
unexpectedly opens revealing enough
space for Alice to enter as she steps
inside the cube seals shut locking her
within the scene then shifts to the
woods where Erica is talking to David
while Paul is sitting at a distance
covering his ears David kisses Erica and
asks if she's ready upon her
confirmation he punches her multiple
times in the face until she's knocked
down even after this he continues to
kick her mercilessly treating her in an
inhuman manner he then undresses her in
order to satisfy himself unbeknownst to
them Alice is filming them from a
distance it turns out that the Black
Cube has transported Alice back in time
giving her a chance to correct her
mistakes after recording the necessary
video footage Alice leaves as she knows
that her father will arrive there soon
it is also revealed that the person whom
Alice and beatric saw earlier outside
the house was none other than Alice but
from the future this is some hermy ass
the following day at 400 p.m. the
present Alice walks towards Paul with
headphones on during this time the
future Alice connects her phone to
Beatrice's caller device and sends the
present version of herself back to to
her mom following this the future
version approaches Adam and asks him to
check outside for David however this
time she hugs him telling him to be
careful before leaving she then goes to
Paul and leads him to the kitchen in
contrast to the Past she lets him help
her in making sandwiches there will be
more pork in this one a few moments
later as Paul leans in for a kiss the
future Alice grabs a kitchen knife and
stabs him in the neck leading to his
death shortly after Erica shows up in
the kitchen and Witnesses her brother
dead which breaks her down into tears
meanwhile Alice freezes in place
realizing that she has become a murderer
Erica then takes the knife from Alice's
hand and stabs her in the stomach before
running away with an excess amount of
blood dripping from the wound Alice
manages to walk up to the living room
where she then collapses a short while
later Adam returns home and is taken a
to discover Paul's dead body in the
kitchen worried about his daughter he
calls out for her and starts searching
for her frantically before long he comes
across her lifeless form in the living
room which leaves him distraught as he
Embraces her in grief the present Alice
walks into the scene and calls out to
him she informs him about the micro
audio chip and allows him to listen to
it although Adam remains uncertain about
the concept of time travel he claims
that he'll try to believe what his
daughter says Alice then tells him about
the Black Cube through which one can
travel back to Any Time merely by
focusing on it she also believes that
Erica and Paul are unrelated to all of
this and have shown up coincidentally
following this she leads her father to
the woods and shows him the cube once
there the cube opens allowing both of
them to enter the scene then cuts to the
opening sequence where a version of Adam
carries a tray of food soon after the
masked man appears behind him and beats
him up until he loses Consciousness the
present Alice hearing the commotion
steps out of her room and finds her
father's body lying motionless on the
ground following this the masked man
enters a room with Erica and Paul and
and reveals himself to be none other
than the future version of Adam this is
getting too complex burn it all down
later that night David enters the house
but Adam is ready to confront him this
time realizing that his plan has failed
David asks about the sibling's
well-being to which Adam responds that
they are safe David then sits in front
of Adam and explains the motive behind
his attempt to kill him according to
David Adam was the one responsible for
the death of his parents leaving him
alone in this whole world it turns out
that Adam was driving with his wife and
Alice when their car collided with
another car this second car was being
driven by David's parents they
unfortunately died in the crash along
with beatric Alice's arm also got
injured in the same incident in the
present while David expresses his
loneliness the future Alice slowly
appears from behind and stabs a knife
into his head following this Alice tells
her father that she must travel back 7
months and 12 days earlier in order to
prevent everything that has happened in
the final scene we see Adam preparing
Alice to time travel a long way back he
instructs her to throw his car keys away
which will prevent the car accident
ultimately saving all of their loved
ones lives you almost wonder why he
didn't do this in the first place the
movie ends as Alice enters the cube
fully motivated to make things right
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching